in previous videos we have already
defined or provided a definition for
energy as the capacity to do work
we have also talked about the notion of
a field we have talked about things like
an electric field or a gravitational
field and these are really mental
constructs that we have produced to
explain force at a distance for example
if i have a planet here and then i have
some other object here that has some
mass we know that these are going to
exert
forces on each other and actually equal
and opposite forces on each other and
scientists said well they're not
touching each other how are they
exerting forces on each other and so
they introduced this notion of a field
that each of these objects produce a
gravitational field of sorts now
einstein came later and said well
actually they're warping space-time etc
etc but a field is one way to think
about how they're able to
induce a force so to speak in each other
similarly if you have two electric
charges let's say you have two negative
point charges like that we know that
they push away on each other that like
charges repel
well they're not touching each other how
do they know to have a force being
applied to them in opposite directions
so once again there's this idea that
each of these produces a field the other
one is in the other electric charges
field and then that field
somehow
applies that force or makes that force
happen to the other thing notice the
field is a useful concept to predict
what will happen and to quantify how it
could happen but it really is just
something in our minds to make sense of
the universe
so with that out of the way let's look
at this water wheel right over here you
can see that the water comes down from
here and then it falls and as it falls
it pushes it fills up these things right
over here which then pushes them down
and then the whole wheel turns and then
that wheel could do work
actually could do useful work in a
physics context not all work is
necessarily useful but this could
actually do useful work so what i want
to think about is two different drops of
water i have a drop of water here maybe
the same drop of water when it's up here
versus once it has gone all the way down
and has been dumped into what i'm
assuming is a stream
down here
now which one has a higher capacity to
do work pause this video and think about
that
well i just told you that when the water
drop is up here it has the capacity as
it falls because of the gravitational
field which is pulling down on it and by
the way if the gravitational field is
pulling down on the water drop that
water drop is also pulling up on earth
but this gravitational field of earth is
pulling down on that water drop and
because of that if we if the water drop
is not supported it can actually do work
in this example on its way to being in
this position right over here
now this position right over here in
theory it could maybe still do work
maybe there's a cliff right over here
and it can continue to pour down but the
water drop up here clearly has the
capacity to do more work because it has
the potential work that it can do from
going from here to here and then
obviously it could then continue to do
any work that this position would allow
it to have
so we would say that this water drop by
virtue of its position has a higher
capacity to do work and has more energy
and what is the form of that energy well
in this case it's gravitational
potential energy it's energy that is
stored and i put that in quotes because
it's not like you're going to be able to
open that water drop and all of a sudden
see energy but it's energy that's stored
by virtue of its position
another way to think about it is instead
of imagining that the energy is stored
in the water drop and it is really
happening in our minds is to say that
that energy is stored in the field in
this case this gravitational field now
the gravitational field is pulling on
this water drop so the direction of
motion would actually reduce the energy
in the field
so if we just let things happen earth's
gravitational field is going to pull on
this water drop and actually that water
drop has a gravitational field that's
going to pull up on earth but as that
water drop gets pulled down the total
amount of energy stored in the field is
going to go down now what happened to
that energy that energy gets transferred
out of the field into kinetic energy of
this wheel which could then be
transferred into other things